[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public notre
objectif vous le connaissez c'est de
vous aider à mieux comprendre
l'actualité donner du sens en donnant du
temps aux meilleurs experts en est
ensemble pendant 90 minutes avec trois
séquences dans cette émission d'abord un
débat d'actualité avec cette question
aujourd'hui la france doit-elle a quitté
l'otan la crise et sous marins
australiens peut-elle être le
déclencheur la réaction pour la création
d'une défense européenne réponse juste
après ses titres
les électeurs ont la parole chaque jour
une question posée par l'une ou l'un
d'entre vous aujourd'hui peut-on éviter
la hausse annoncée de 10 % des tarifs de
l'électricité au mois de janvier vous
entendrez notamment le président du ufc
que choisir
et puis le troisième temps de son ce
public c'est un débat prospectif en
décalage avec l'actualité en tout cas
l'actualité du jour on se demandera tout
à l'heure si anne hidalgo est en train
de réaliser un hold up au parti
socialiste et surtout quelles sont ses
chances de percer dans cette campagne
présidentielle
mais d'abord les conséquences
diplomatiques de la perte de ce contrat
de 12 sous marins australiens plusieurs
voix s'élèvent pour réclamer une sortie
de l'otan l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord cécile 6 où je
souhaite mettre sur la table la
participation de la france au
commandement intégré de l'otan le signal
fort que la france devrait renvoyer
aujourd'hui c'est de quitter le
commandement armé de l'otan xavier
bertrand jean luc mélenchon fabien
roussel ou encore jordan bardella quatre
jours après la rupture du contrat des
douze sous marin avec l'australie des
membres de l'opposition réclament au
gouvernement le retrait de la france de
l'otan des demandes absurdes selon le
sénateur christian cambon je pense que
tout ça ces agitations de deux candidats
aux élections présidentielles qui tente
de surfer sur cet événement mais je
pense que ils sont vraiment bien mal
informés de la réalité car selon
philippe etienne l'ambassadeur de france
aux états unis ni la france ni les états
unis ne souhaitent aller aussi loin plan
de la sécurité bien sûr nous avons
besoin des américains en europe certes
l'europe en général c'est le sens de
l'alliance atlantique mais je crois que
les américains ont aussi le désir de
continuer à travailler avec nous notre
armée est très respecté aux états unis
tous ceux qui contribuent à la sécurité
globale tous ceux qui tout ce que la
france donne comme contribution est très
très respecté aux états unis la
sénatrice nathalie goulet qui a demandé
la mise en place d'une commission
denquête estime que la france ne doit
pas réagir sous l'effet de la colère il
faut réfléchir à la réplique il faut
qu'elle soit coordonnée il faut qu'elle
soit aux puissantes et le parlement ils
soient associés il n'empêche qu'il faut
quand même avoir quelques explications
sur les conditions de cette rupture des
explications qui devraient être
apportées par la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat qui est d'ores et
déjà prévu de mener des auditions sur
les conditions de rupture de ce contrat
la france va-t-elle quitter l'otan pour
en débattre j'accueille sylvie matelly
bonjour
vous êtes économiste directrice adjointe
de l'iris vous avez récemment publié
géopolitique de l'économie céder aux
éditions eyrolles christian makarian
bonjour un jour vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste des questions
internationales
olivier cadic sénateurs bonjour des
français établis hors de france vice
président de la commission des finances
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées matthieu croissandeau
bonjou l'éditorialiste de sens public
les lundis et mercredis bienvenu.merci
de d'avoir haut la main occuper ce
fauteuil jeudi dernier c'est un plaisir
c'était un bonheur partagé par toute
l'équipe et puis avec nous en
visioconférence nicole bacharan la
politologue
bonjour nicole bienvenue vous publiez
avec de loïc simonet les grands jours
qui ont changé l'amérique c'est chez
perrin peut-être avant de répondre à la
question du débat posé un tout petit peu
le décor rappeler de trois éléments de
base l'otan créée le 4 avril 1949
signature du traité de washington
le siège est à bruxelles 30 pays membres
dont la france les états unis et le
royaume uni pas l'australie il faut le
il faut le rappeler à christian makarian
entière je commence avec vous c'est quoi
le l'otan c'est une alliance aussi
politique que militaire c'est quoi
exactement nous c'est fondamentalement
une alliance militaire
défensive qui est née évidemment de la
guerre froide et qui a eu du mal après
la chute du mur de berlin à se
transformer on se souvient très bien que
le président macron a utilisé une
formule très forte et il y a deux ans
pour la qualifier en disant que l'otan
était alors en état de mort cérébrale ça
veut dire que y'a un problème de
concepts que signifie une alliance
atlantique qui regroupe des pays baltes
qui regroupe des pays qui font partie
l'union européenne des pays qui n'en
font pas partie et toute une série
deux concepts s'entrechoquent pour
définir tout cela est évidemment à
l'intérieur de l'otan la turquie la
turquie qui se permet par ailleurs
d'acheter des missiles s-400 russe qui
est totalement contraire à l'esprit de
l'otan alors tout le débat et a été posé
sur la table par la présidence de donald
trump donald trump a notamment de ça
coûte trop cher ça coûte trop cher et ça
c'est vrai les européens ne paye pas
assez et c'est vrai que plus de 70 % de
la charge de cette année on se repose
sur les états unis on peut considérer
que c'est pas normal là-dessus trump
avait des raisons cela dit ruff est allé
très loin il a refusé de confirmer
l'efficacité de l'oeuf du fameux article
5 un article qui prévoit l'entr'aide au
cas où un des pays de l'alliance serait
agressé par un ennemi extérieur tous les
autres se porter à son secours et trump
a refusé de confirmer clairement et
nettement que cet article était toujours
en vigueur donc ce qui est ce qui a fait
peser une menace et qui a fait peur à
tout le monde et on s'est dit
si j'ose dire pardon je renverse le
micro mais ce monsieur tron risque de
complètement mettre fin à l'otan alors
ça n'a pas été le cas mais aujourd'hui
on est face à une situation et j'en
termine où l'otan doit l'an prochain au
sommet qui va avoir lieu à madrid
remettre sur la table son nouveau
concept stratégique lequel c'est tout le
problème car il faut un nouveau conseil
stratégique pour sortir justement de la
mort cérébrale parce que
sylvie matelly on peut donc moi j'écoute
cris sur ma carrière on peut
légitimement se demander à quoi ça sert
aujourd'hui et beaucoup se sont demandés
depuis la fin de la guerre froide très
clairement après
objectivement parlant est comme ça a
très bien été dit pas par monsieur ma
carrière les états unis financent ou
assument eux près de 70% des dépenses de
l'otan au grand dam de donne entre
donald trump en son temps donc l'otan
clairement financées grâce au
financement des états unis permet
d'assurer la sécurité européenne et
sécurité des européens et au delà de
dudu du manque de solidarité de donald
trump au delà le manque de volonté de
donald trump d'assurer la solidarité ont
rejoint cette affaire australienne
quelque part parce que au fond ce manque
de solidarité ne concernait pas que les
pays de l'otan c'est vrai qu'il ya un
certain nombre de doutes qui se sont
élevées parmi les alliés des etats unis
sur la capacité des états unis à venir
les protéger parce que les états unis
n'ont pas protégé que les européens
pendant des décennies c'était le cas
également du japon de l'australie et
donc on retrouve aujourd'hui finalement
un certain nombre d'alliés des états
unis qui se disent mais est ce que les
états unis ne sont pas de retour et ce
qu'on ne doit pas à nouveau leur faire
confiance et là se joue un certain
nombre de choses en europe et dans
l'attitude française dans cette affaire
parce que très clairement on sent bien
qu'il ya un certain nombre de pays
européens qui ne suivront pas les yeux
fermés la france dans son engagement à
l'encontre des états unis dans cette
affaire des sous marins donc on voit cc
c'est une affaire qui est extrêmement
complexe et où tout un ensemble de
facteurs interviennent en fait et dans
ce débat on va forcément parler de la
chine je vous donner la parole dans une
seconde mais je voudrais entre comme
dans tant de nicole bacharan tout de
suite parce que c'est cette cette
stratégie américaine nicole dans ce
dossier des sous marins australiens
c'est évidemment en regardant la chine
que joe bein nagy c'est ce qu'il faut
rappeler
oui tout à fait et ça il s'agit
effectivement
de la perception de la menace chinoise
et la perception est beaucoup plus aigu
du côté des états unis et du côté de
l'australie et c'est une des raisons des
lacs d'ailleurs pour laquelle il ya eu
ce problème avec le contrat sur les sous
marins dans les dernières années entre
la signature est aujourd'hui les
australiens ont réellement pris peur sa
soi disant nouvelle agressivité dans
toute la conduite de la chine notamment
après les célébrations du 100e
anniversaire du parti communiste chinois
ce discours très offensif de docks cgt
il y avait des problèmes industriels
avec ce contrat les retards les coûts
qu'elle mente et là il faut quand même
pas d'exiger que ce genre de marché
c'est un marché mondial mais où les
acteurs ne sont pas très nombreux et ils
s'observent de prêts et la france
commence à avoir une mauvaise réputation
par exemple avec deux fameuses p r qui
de plus en plus cher et qui n'arrive
jamais à terme qui a une mauvaise
réputation française malheureusement qui
s'est un peu à ce culte dans cette
affaire sur le plan industriel et dans
les dernières années gamin il ya eu un
énorme problème de piratage de documents
liés au travail sur les sous marins donc
ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que l'on
peut voir d'où vient la décision la
décision australienne par contre la
manière dont les américains ont traité
la france ils ont vu l'avantagé immédiat
d'une alliance petit solide face à la
chine et ils ont écarté vraiment d'un
revers de main extrêmement méprisant le
viel à aigaliers pilier l'otan qui est
la france et on voit que d'abord dans un
premier temps à washington dans citi
bron aller laisse penser m'en aller mais
ça va passer et qu'entre temps la
réaction quand même très forte est me
semble-t-il
justifier le la france les amène à se
dire que l'ifo à la fois se réconcilier
et puis peut-être envisager des
négociations réellement négociations sur
la stratégie européenne américaine
australienne dans l'inde au pacifique et
qu'on ne peut pas
mépriser ainsi la france et c'est aussi
le nôtre sujet aujourd'hui fragilisées
ainsi l'otan toute fissure au sein de
l'otan est pain béni pour la russie et
la chine merci ni quand je reviens vers
vous tout à l'heure olivier cadic il
faut quand même on l'a pas encore dit
mais on n'a pas été bons dans ce dossier
notre diplomatie nous renseignements
n'ont pas été bon non je pense qu'il
faut quand même pas aller tout le tort
faire l'autocritique en permanence c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle ce ce qui vient
de se passer ça a des effets ça a été
dit tout à l'heure ça des effets
économiques va falloir enquêter analyser
ça parce que derrière c'est des emplois
donc il ya des gens qui craignent
aujourd'hui pour leur emploi donc il
faut essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé il faut évaluer
ensuite il faut comprendre les raisons
qui ont amené peut-être l'australie à
prendre cette décision donc il faut
regarder the big picture comme on dit
donc la problématique nouvelle qui est
la poussée de la chine qui se fait de
plus en plus forte en trois ans la chine
a créé au niveau du de sa marine
l'équivalent de la marine française
simplement trois ans entre 2015 et 2018
il ya une poussée très forte aurait donc
c'est une année de plus rendu forte
aujourd'hui sur taïwan et les américains
savent bien que si puisque la chine veut
prendre le leadership mondial d'ici 2049
il le
lider maximo chinois xi jinping a bien
dit qu'il fallait killer récupère taiwan
à l'intérieur de la chine d'ici là et ce
sera fait par tous moyens y compris
l'invasion et on sait très bien que si
ça va jusque là les américains seront
amenées à s'engager et l'australie est
directement dans la ligne de mire ça a
été clairement dit aussi il ya tout un
développement du charles power chinois
qui est justement maintenant qui devient
très agressif au niveau de la comment
dire de l'agression par par les médias
parlent influence par le fait qu' on va
vous voyez qu'il se passe quelque chose
comme ça on va s'autocritiquer il est
quand même un peu justifié christian
makarian l'autocritique dans un cirque
oui oui elle est totalement justifiée
mais je trouve que monsieur le sénateur
a très bien expliqué et je crois qu'il
faut pas se tromper que l'agression ne
vient pas vis-à-vis de la france des
etats-unis mais l'agression initiale
provient de la chine c'est la chine qui
a obligé la l'australie à réviser ses
fondamentaux je vais vous donner un
exemple très concret la france a vendu
des sous marins qui ne sont pas à
propulsion nucléaire alors que la france
fabrique d'excellence
l'australie ne l'a pas désiré parce que
l'australie ainsi que la nouvelle
zélande a dans ces éléments fondateurs
l'interdiction
de faire rentrer des sous marins à
propulsion naturel dans ces ports ni à
l'australie nyon nouvelle zélande bon là
visiblement la doctrine australienne a
changé puisqu'il achète des sous marins
à propulsion north american pu sentir à
voir des signes avant-coureurs sa pardon
d'être un peu têtu oui mais vous avez
raison il ya un énorme défaut de
renseignement et un énorme défaut de
vision stratégique
le contrat entre la signature du contrat
en 2016 et 2021
la dénonciation il est vrai un peu on va
le dire mufle de ce contrat franchement
le monde a changé et le tort que peuvent
avoir
les autorités françaises cedapa de ne
pas avoir saisi à quel point tout ça a
été friable et évolutif mais ce n'est
pas le fait de la france ce n'est pas le
feu le fait des états unis ce n'est pas
le fait de l'australie c'est le fait de
la chine la chine a changé comme l'a dit
très clairement monsieur sénateurs total
à changer de braquet elle est devenue
extrêmement agressive je rappelle qu'ils
sont en train les chinois d'achever leur
troisième porte avions mais que leur
programme porte sur 7 et que les états
unis tout au tout compris elles ont 13
donc ils vont arriver d'ici quatre ou
cinq ans à la moitié de la foi de deux
porte-avions des etats-unis a donné ça
change toute la donne dans le dos au
pacifique donc les australiens
révisent leurs fondamentaux stratégiques
moi je trouve ça normal en revanche
qu'il le fasse avec ce degré de muflerie
même de grossièretés c'est évidemment
insupportable pour la france et la
france à raison de protester de faire
monter la tension et de marquer le coup
même beaucoup plus que ça de marquer sur
l'indignation dans la perspective de la
révision du concept stratégique de
l'otan qui va avoir lieu l'an prochain
en juin à madrid 2022 alors voilà je
voulais poser quand même le décor appris
ce qu'était l'otan ce qui était les
enjeux autour de ce contrat mais j'en
viens maintenant la question du du débat
la france doit-elle quitté l'otan elle
fait partie des pays fondateurs elle
s'est retirée du commandement intégré en
66 évidemment sous général de gaulle
2009 réintégration du commandement
intégré à l'époque sarkozy sinématiali
qu'est ce que vous répondez à la
question générale de ce débat est-ce
qu'il faut partir pour marquer le coup
diplomatiquement et si oui quelles
conséquences est-ce qu'on part d'une
alliance
avec cette histoire et puis qu'on a fini
par
joindre encore
récemment sans raison et juste parce
qu'on a été froissé pourquoi partirais
me semble disproportionné
tout à fait et surtout de quoi se
prive-t-on pourquoi partir et on commet
partirait ton qu'elle on serait quelle
serait l'alternative à notre départ ça
paraît effectivement comme ça a été dit
dans votre reportage des propositions
très électoraliste en fait qu'ils
peuvent parler à une certaine partie de
l'opinion publique française mais dans
la vraie vie se passe quoi si on part il
se passe quoi il se passe probablement
qu'il nous faut augmenter massivement
nos dépenses militaires qui nous faut
assumer notre défense tout seul parce
que les européens ne nous suivrons pas
sur ceux sur cette affaire là donc les
conséquences peuvent être extrêmement
forte et extrêmement importante faut
faire attention avec ce type de avec ce
type de proposition à l'instant l'agencé
france presse qui nous apprend que joe
biden et je cite un patient de
s'entretenir avec les manuels macro
alors c'est pas joe biden qui le dit
lui-même mais c'est une source une
source indirecte qu'est ce qu'ils vont
bien pouvoir se raconter
aux gens des choses je dis alors je vais
poser la question différemment quelle
est la stratégie de joe biden
après cette crise c'est quoi ces deux
ont calmé le président français mais
peut-être de le réintégrer au processus
un peu ce que disait nicole bacharan
tout à l'heure ce qu'il peut faire pour
essayer de faire passer la pilule qui ne
passera quand même pas un mais c'est
rappeler tous les domaines de
coopération intense entre la france et
états unis qui sent comme dirait trump
saxe est folle qui sont vraiment des
réussites par exemple le mali on a
besoin des américains en syrie trump
s'est unilatéralement retirer mais enfin
et ça fait beaucoup souffrir les
positions françaises et britanniques
mais enfin quand même on à coopérer avec
eux pendant des années et il ya
évidemment l'épisode de l'afghanistan où
déjà byden avait envoyé un signal en ne
prévenant pas ses alliés donc si j'ose
dire on a déjà une une connotation assez
clair des méthodes de l'administration
byden qui seront brutale direct qui
tiendront assez peu compte des alliés
donc tout ça ils peuvent se le dire mais
nous avons eu aussi une coopération très
intéressante même sous trump en avril le
13 entre dans la nuit du 13 au 14 avril
2018 les britanniques les français et
les américains ont bombardé la syrie
parce que la syrie tout simplement avait
utilisé des armes chimiques
ce qui avait été déjà défini par une
ligne comme une ligne rouge par obama
qui n'avait pas inspecté rien rouge mais
cette fois là ça et
je rappelle que depuis ce raid franco
britannico américain il n'y a plus d'
usage d'armes chimiques par le régime
assad et au passage on envoyait un
message très clair aux russes dites à
votre copain assad qu'il arrête de faire
souffrir les populations civiles avec
des armes chimiques ça on l'a fait avec
les américains
donc ce que les deux présidents pour
répondre à votre question thomas peuvent
se dire ce qu en tout cas le président
américain peut dire au président
français sait mais regardez tout ce que
nous avons fait ensemble qui était
réussie on va continuer la france a
besoin aussi des états unis en afrique
il ya beaucoup de domaines de
coopération
mais au passage et c'est la question
fondamentale pour la diplomatie
française nous dit rabanel notre ennemi
notre adversaire c'est la chine est ce
que la france doit emboîter le pas et ça
c'est la question fondamentale et suivre
les états unis dans ce nouveau combat
contre la chine comme certains ont suivi
les états unis en irak ce que nous
n'avons pas fait ou bien en afghanistan
alors troisième voie entre la solution
doit suivre les américains sachant quand
même qu'ils se sont plantés en irak
gravement planté en afghanistan
gravement est-ce qu'ils vont pas encore
nous entraîner dans une aventure quand
même sans lendemain contre la chine
c'est ça le débat fondamental c'est ça
la question qu'il faut débattre
aujourd'hui en france olivier cadic
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous
répondez à cette question il faut
inventer une voie diplomatique face à la
chine
tout d'abord justement faut pas avoir
d'affect dans cette affaire c'est la
science et l'art était absolument c'est
ça il faut dépasser le moment du choc il
faut pas surtout pas avoir d'affect
ensuite écouté la chine nous le montre
la chine ça remet à toute vitesse et je
pense que des états unis tout seul
n'arriveront pas à répondre donc il ya
d'autres pays qui ont dans la zone
besoin aussi de sous marins donc je
pense qu'il ya des possibilités aussi
pour nous de vendre à d'autres pays les
sous-marins qui n'auront pas été
revendue à l'australie tout ça ça
analyse avec les pays de la zone il faut
que tout le monde soit bien conscient
effectivement que il ya la chine mais il
ya aussi la russie qui nous pose un
certain nombre de difficultés et que
l'on sait très bien il ya aussi des
plans qu'ils existent que si il ya
l'invasion de taiwan en même temps la
russie peut profiter de ce moment là
pour intervenir sur les pays l'ukraine
la géorgie il ya des tas de plans de
scénario qui nous sont présentés comme
ça de façon à ce que ça de potentialités
de conflit pour éviter que ça ne soit
une déflagration complète donc on doit
se préparer à tout ça par rapport à tous
les laits ravi vous savez qu'ils sont en
train de parfois en train de discuter
des problématiques nationales purement
nationales on est aujourd'hui en guerre
au niveau 6 bert dans l'espace les
menaces les conflits on les a déjà au
quotidien donc là on sent les pressions
ce qu'on entendait au début du du sujet
de cécile tout à l'heure qui réclament
justement la sortie de l'otan pour vous
sondez ravi mais donner encore une fois
ils veulent faire un coup et ça a été
très bien dit par le président cambon
juste au début il faut dépasser ce côté
d'aphex côté de campagne électorale où
on souhaite existé devant les caméras un
moment pour faire la différence avec son
concurrent là on parle de encore une
fois de notre destin commun qui dépasse
le côté français qui embrase le toute
l'europe mais aussi qui réunit toutes
les démocraties on est face à une
puissance qui nie les démocraties qui va
contre ce système qu'ils appellent
occidental ils veulent imposer un autre
domaine est ce qu'un autre une autre
façon de vivre ensemble est ce qu'on a
envie de vivre comme les chinois je ne
crois pas non pas comme les chinois
comme le veut le parti communiste
chinois voilà est-ce qu'on veut de ce
modèle là non c'est clair et donc on a
besoin de créer des alliances alors
après il faut pas non plus être comment
dire faut être conscient que on est
aussi en concurrence avec l'industrie de
la défense américaine et là aussi quand
on dit on veut être l'europe on veut
alors sa renommée face aux états unis on
joue le en même temps et il côté
anglo-saxon ça peut être interprété
comme une sorte de prise de distance on
va laisser sur la question de l'europe
de la défense et de ce qui peut se faire
alors qu'il ya pas mal d'entreprises
concurrentes aujourd'hui pas et pas
forcément à liés économiquement matthieu
croissandeau j'aurais convient dans une
politique de de cette affaire parce que
il n'ya pas que le traité de de
l'atlantique nord kaka du plan d'eau
relais en tout cas qui a été critiqué
dans cette campagne présidentielle oui
alors là on en voit évidemment xavier
bertrand aussi jean luc mélenchon le 10
ou le code dit la communiste réclamer la
sortie de l'otan
mais c'est le nouveau refrain à la mode
en fait beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
candidats veulent sortir des traités en
commençant bien sûr par tous ces traités
qui nous empêchent nos ancêtres nous
contraignent alors selon qu'on est de
gauche de droite c'est pas forcément les
mêmes à tout seigneur tout honneur ou
sans surprise les insoumis jean luc
mélenchon dont il faut souligner comme
une certaine constance en la matière
promettre de s'affranchir de la plupart
des traités européens existants les
renégociant ça c'est le fameux plan à ou
si ça marche pas en les quittant c'est
le non moins fameux plan b pour
appliquer notre programme il nous faudra
désobéir la commission est déchiré les
traités des insoumis toutes nos misères
écologique et sociale ont leur origine
dans le contenu de ces traités avait
lancé jean luc mélenchon 2019 dans une
tribune qui s'appelait sortait des
traités stupide et ce n'est plus le seul
à en faire un cheval de bataille non
alors quand on regarde ces cinq est
assez étonnant parce qu'au fond on a
évidemment françois asselineau qui
réclame n'offre excitons à nicolas
dupont aignan tout ça on connaît un peu
mais une partie de la droite et
l'extrême droite entend bien elle aussi
dénoncé d'autres traités pas seulement
les critères de maastricht à commencer
par celui qui fonde la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme par exemple la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ou celui de la cour de justice
européenne et de la même manière en gros
que jean luc mélenchon on reproche au
pacte de stabilité de l'empêcher de
mener la politique économique et sociale
qu'il voudrait mettre en place une
partie de la droite dénonce ces deux
traités n'a enfin la cause de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme où la
cour de justice européenne en disant que
ça ne nous permet pas de mener la
politique migratoire ou de sécurité
qu'elle souhaiterait mettre en place
alors là on a deux amours
marine le pen en passant par eric ciotti
même le très européen enfin celui qui
était très européen michel barnier s'en
est pris aux piliers de l'union
européenne il faut retrouver notre
souveraineté juridique pour ne plus être
soumis aux arrêts de la cjr
donc la cour de justice de l'union
européenne ou de la cdh la fameuse cour
européenne des droits de l'homme at-il
twitté alors ça fait un tollé il a fini
par effacer son tweet mais il maintient
son propos bref on y voit plus très
clair il proposait un référendum sur sur
succession de numéros exactement toi
qu'est-ce que ça traduit ça traduit en
fait on je pense qu'on assiste à la
deuxième lame souverainiste la première
elle était portée par des marginaux
chacun dans leur propre camp et avec des
souverainistes de droite et des
souverainistes de gauche aujourd'hui
c'est une lame de fond qui touche à peu
près tous les partis politiques c'est
une tentative au fond de réponse on peut
la juger facile ou non mais aux
inquiétudes générées évidemment par la
mondialisation par le fait que les
problèmes d'identité et primes de
sécurité que ce soit de l'emploi et
prennent de sécurité tout court mais
c'est aussi et surtout un bon moyen de
trouver un bouc émissaire et de données
facilement dans la démagogie parce que
raser gratis c'est facile vous faire ce
qu'on a dit c'est beaucoup plus
difficile souvenez-vous dernier françois
hollande je vais renégocier le pacte de
stabilité ça c'était jusqu'aux derniers
jours de la campagne un mois après on
est en juin 2012 il va voir madame
merkel est il le signe et même jean marc
ayrault reconnaîtra quelques mois plus
tard qu'il ne l'a pas renégocier ce que
la vérité c'est que c'est compliqué
dénoncé un traité 1 demander à nos amis
anglais ça n'a pas été facile et surtout
même de façon unilatérale c'est un jeu
où il ya beaucoup de coups à prendre et
beaucoup de coups politiques à assumer
imaginez que nous on dénonce les traités
qui nous arrange pas d'accord mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait si le luxembourg
l'irlande disney qui sorte de traité sur
la fiscalité qui sont d accord qui a
qu'est ce qu'on fait si la pologne dit
mais moi je sors des accords sur le
travail qu'est ce qu'on fait si l' on
vit sort sur les droits de l'homme au
secours ce qu'on a commencé à voir eh
ben c'est l'implosion de l'europe donc
c'est très compliqué merci mathieu pour
pour cette analyse je me tourne vers un
ver nicole bacharan peut-être pour pour
continue pour tirer le fil un peu plus
politique pour dire un mot quand même de
la stratégie de joe biden et ce
sentiment qu'on a c'est dans c'est ce
que disait christian makarian tout à
l'heure où il filme fait quand même du
trump aussi joe biden dans cette affaire
une certaine façon oui dans le temps
dans l'art et la manière aujourd'hui de
dire que vous avez rappelé un instant
thomas que joe biden était impatient de
parler avec emmanuel macron qui le fait
un petit peu attendre ce qui est de
bonne guerre mais vu les circonstances
mais à une autre annonce il ya à peu
près une heure les états unis lèvent
vont lever plus tôt
jordan l'interdiction de voyager qui
pesait sur les européens depuis le
printemps 2001 même vacciner même testé
les européens n'avaient pas le droit de
se rendre aux états unis et je pense
qu'on peut voir dans cette annonce une
espèce de comment dire l'amba qui est
qu'il y à la maison blanche et au
département d'état face à la réaction
très vive des français et on désire de
se concilier les a niés et de les
rassurer parce que comme je le disais il
ya un instant toute fissure dans
l'alliance est observé avec beaucoup
d'appétit en russie et en russie et en
et en chine et c'est ce qui vient d'être
dit d'ailleurs sur ce fantasme de sortir
de l'otan renégocier les traités c'est
exactement du donald trump cia n'avait
il pas promis de renégocier l'accord de
paris où il allait en sortir l'accord de
paris sur le climat il n'a rien pu
négocier du tout et il en est sorti et
les etats unis ont ils sont revenus
parce que c'est la seule chose
raisonnable affaires donald trump avait
promis de renégocier un bien meilleur
accord sur le nucléaire iranien ou tout
cas pendant tout son mandat
il n'en a rien été et quand on voit en
france les voix qui s'élèvent pour
sortir de l'otan à l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche et xavier bertrand qui
visiblement fait des appels du pied à
l'électorat
lectorat l'extrême droite c'est pure
votre mental électorale ça n'a aucun
sens et c'est absurde voire grotesque sa
part de l'idée que la france tout seul
si elle ne fait pas de vague n'a pas
l'ennemi n'a pas de menace qui pèsent
sur elle qu'elle peut s'isoler de
l'agressivité chinoise russe qui
s'exprime de toutes les manières dont ça
a été très bien dit sur les plateaux ça
n'a aucun sens et c'est vrai que
l'alliance atlantique
fragilisée en donald trump qui voit la
met en cause la solidarité des membres
de l'alliance si jamie bell pas
suffisamment l'heure leurs quotas
là les états unis d'aujourd'hui qui
méprise la france pilier autre biais de
l'alliance c'est absolument très mauvais
et je compris reste là dessus juste en
disant que c'est vrai que la manière
bailon que vous rapprochez celle de
donald trump et je pense que vous avez
raison avec une manière dont c'est fait
la sortie d'afghanistan la manière dont
ces gérer cette rupture du contrat avec
l'australie
j'ose espérer lui leur embarras comme
aujourd'hui qu'ils en tireront quelques
leçons il suffit pas d'avoir un but à
atteindre
sortir l'afghanistan où fonder un
nouveau groupe aux caisses et
united kingdom pardon royaume uni etats
unis australie face à la chine et ne
suffit pas d'atteindre nos buts qui ont
pas faire 2 les gars autour j'espère
qu'ils vont apprendre un peu plus merci
une école sylvie matelly je reviens au
contrat lui-même peut-être que c'est
absurde ce que je vais dire à ce moment
là vous m'excuserez mais est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que finalement la france
re rentrer par la fenêtre c'est pas eu
facile de faire entrer un sous marin par
une fenêtre mais voyez ce que je veux
dire est ce que c'est fini fini ou est
ce que finalement dans le jeu le bras de
fer la diplomatique qui est en train de
se se jouer on va vers nantes ans nicole
bacharan dire où là on va de nouveau
avoir les les français qui peuvent
retourner aux états unis il ya des gages
qui sont manifestement donné par
l'administration américaine est ce que
ça pourrait revenir dans le contrat
je ne pense pas si on regarde pourquoi
les australiens ont fait ce choix et ça
a été dit à plusieurs reprises les
australiens ont fait ce choix parce
qu'ils se sentent de plus en plus
menacée avec la chine le ton a fortement
monté jusqu'à des propos qui ont été
tenus dans la presse chinoise au
printemps dernier qu'il n'excluait pas
de frapper l'australie si l'australie
venait à être solidaire de taiwan en cas
d'une attaque dont ça a été très très
loin il ya l'embargo sur les
importations de produits australiens
faut rappeler que le commerce de
l'australie avec la chine c'est un tiers
des exportations d'australie donc
jusqu'à très récemment l'australie a
quand même essayé de préserver ses
relations économiques et puis les choses
se sont tellement gâtés que ça n'est
plus possible donc si on part de là il
est assez logique que les australiens
soit allé chercher la protection
américaine et effet relativement peu
confiance à allah allah français aux
européens qui eux sont plutôt sur une
ligne plus modérée dans la relation à la
chine gagne on en fait un rival
systémique mais aussi en concurrent
économique mais aussi un partenaire sur
un certain nombre de dossiers et ça n'a
peut être pas rassuré l'australie
voisin de la chine donc de ce point de
vue là on voit mal les australiens
revenir sur le dossier par contre il est
clair que les états unis et des
américains de joe biden vont avoir
intérêt à donner des gages aux français
mais plus largement aux européens pour
permet pour permettre pour conduire les
européens à suivre
leurs alliés dans cette approche à la
chine et dans cette relation à la chine
donc on peut on pourrait avoir des
surprises effectivement dans les mois ou
les semaines qui viennent et peut-être
que cette annonce ce soir comme le
disait nicole machin est un premier pas
vers un adoucissement des relations avec
l'anc alors se poser la question d'une
défense européenne et peut-être pour
commencer écoutez le le ministre des
affaires étrangères il disait que
l'europe est tout simplement en train de
sortir de l'innocent c'est pas trop tôt
hop est en train de sortir de
l'innocence mais ça se sent alors je
suis quand même mais ça sent l'urgence
et après l'afghanistan et cette affaire
je pense que si l'europe si les
européens ne sont pas qu'il faut rester
dans l'histoire est que s'ils veulent
rester dans l'histoire il faut qu'ils
s'unissent et qu'ils défendent ensemble
à propos intérêt alors leur destin sera
totalement différent et nous ne pouvons
pas aller dans cette direction des
fastes alors cette question de l'europe
de la défense on va s'offrir un petit
rappel avec quentin calme est revenu et
nous quand un bonsoir bonsoir donc
évidemment ses doutes relance la
question c'est ce qu'on disait autour de
cette europe de la défense oui et ce à
un serpent de mer ouvrait cette question
la pause depuis plusieurs décennies et
dans l'union européenne mais vous l'avez
rappelé avec la chute du mur de berlin
également la fin de l'union de l'urss
certains ont voulu relancer porté cette
idée d'une politique étrangère de la
sécurité commune d'ailleurs cette
expression elle apparaît dans le traité
de maastricht en 1192 ce processus il
s'est accéléré ces dernières années et
on l'a vu notamment lorsqu'il ya eu deux
informations on va les revoir rapidement
en 2018 voilà vous le voyez c'est
lorsque bien donald trump a dénoncé le
coût de l'otan la deuxième info c'était
en 2019 donc juste après lorsque minima
qu'on a parlé de cette mort cérébrale de
l'otan et bien c'est pile à ce moment là
que l'allemagne a proposé est bien de
lancer une réflexion avec tous les états
membres de l'union européenne
des chaque pays peut comme cela a
contribué à la réflexion sur la
stratégie et puis membres doivent
aboutir d'ailleurs à une synthèse autour
de ces travaux en mars 2022 ça tombe
bien puisque la france sera à ce moment
là à la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne la france qui est d'ailleurs
un très volontaire dans ce dossier
qu'est ce qui manque qu'est ce qui
bloque concrètement et bien une
autonomie stratégique de lieux par
rapport à l'otan c'est rédhibitoire pour
plusieurs pays européens comme la suède
comme elle les états baltes également
ces pays ont très peur de ce pc du
parapluie militaire américain aussi la
défense saint pholien ça coûte très cher
alors en attendant une idée revient chez
les promoteurs de cette europe de la
défense c'est de créer une force
militaire constituée de 2 battle group
ont dit c'est à dire à peu près 5000
hommes et qui pourrait répondre en cas
de crise importante
une sorte de jalons assez modeste on
peut le dire un thomas mais vers une
défense européenne et qui ne serait pas
exclusive de l'otan ces débats en tout
cas s'annonce de plus en plus intense
d'ici au 1er semestre 2009 1 2 et par
exemple il en sera question est bien
lors du prochain conseil européen ce
sera en novembre prochain merci quand un
quentin calmer la rédaction de public
sénat qui vous accompagne tous les jours
dans cette dans cette émission
ce sénateur olivier cadic une europe de
la défense et comme comme le disait
quant à un serpent de mer est ce que
cette crise peut servir d'accélérateur
d'après vous oui je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une prise de
conscience pour l'europe que
on a un destin commun et que si on est
en conflit avec la vision américaine eh
bien il faut être capable de s'assumer
et là actuellement on a effectivement un
leader à l'otan qui et les états unis
d'amérique et pour diriger une alliance
ben c'est comme pour diriger une armée
napoléon disait mieux vaut un mauvais
général que de bons donc là aujourd'hui
on a un mauvais général peut-être c'est
comme ça que c'est perçu chez nous mais
toujours est il que on a besoin d'une
unicité or là peut-être effectivement la
question va se poser c'est au niveau de
l'europe est ce que on commence on
oriente notre stratégie en commençant à
dire écoutez on va aussi
défendre nos propres intérêts et on
commence à le voir par exemple avec le
cloud souverain on en voit bien qu'on
essaye de se détacher de plus en plus
des états unis de prendre notre d'avoir
une souveraineté européenne
c'est effectivement le sens de la
démarche initiée il faut le dire par la
france donc c'est ce que l'on cherche à
faire mais et ça a été dit
d'autres pays européens ne vont pas
aller dans ce sens d'un dut même pas que
nous donc c'est toute la difficulté pour
l'europe de ce signifiant et de décider
de prendre cette décision forte mais
ceci étant si on le fait ça aura aussi
des répercussions avec les états unis
si je vous entends bien c'est plus une
question de stratégie que de moyens on a
les moyens de se
s'offrir une défense christian makarian
oui et de volonté les gens se retiennent
mes volontés alors il ya une stratégie
qui peut être efficace qui est celle
suivie par la france et celle de la
constitution d'un noyau dur avec
l'allemagne
d'élargir ce néo dur notamment ya un
gros volet industriel qui est
l'industrie d'armement qu'il faut qu'on
fabrique des armes en commun parce que
là dans les 27 pays il ya 27 budget avec
des taux par rapport au pib différents
ce qui énervait monsieur trump il ya
aussi énormément d'industrie de la
défense tout à fait autonome concurrence
mais les français ne savent pas que par
exemple l'appui tchèque produits
d'excellente arme de poing et même d'une
d'artillerie donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec tout ça il faut l'harmoniser tout
ça est sous l'énorme autant parce qu'il
ya des normes d'usagé des munitions des
calibres et c'est qu'ils sont définis
par l'otan enfin c'est quand même des
industries nationales il faut aussi
régler le problème des intérêts
économiques est ce que nous français
nous avons envie soyons honnêtes de
passer sous un commandement
inter européen qui déciderait des
industries dans telle ou telle portion
du territoire avec des suppressions
d'emplois possible ou des regroupements
c'est assez
difficile et puis derrière ça il ya
aussi comme vous l'avez dit thomas le
concept pour faire quoi
l'adjoint des états unis qui donneront
les ordres ou être nous mêmes donneurs
d'ordre et c'est très difficile puisque
nous n'avons pas par exemple la même
orientation par rapport à la russie un
pays comme la pologne est déchaînée avec
de bonnes raisons contre la russie les
pays baltes aussi la suède aussi puisque
les sous-marins russes visitent
régulièrement les eaux territoriales
territoriales suédoises nous n'avons pas
cette menace là nous en avons d'autres
par exemple
l'opération barque anomalie nous avons
d'autres polarité quant aux allemands
qui sont au milieu ils sont plutôt
portés vers l'est que vers le sud de
l'europe il faut régler tous ces
problèmes là c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça n'aboutit pas mais je
rappelle qu'en 1954 il ya eu un grand
projet qui s'appelait la commune la cod
comme une communauté européenne de
défense que la france y est opposée
parce que déjà sa supposée une partie du
démantèlement de la souveraineté
française sur saône a pas et militaires
donc oui il ya vraiment beaucoup de
problèmes c'est pas c'est pas qu'une
question d'incapacité je voudrais juste
faire une précision au débat sur
l'australie parce que c'est très
important
les deux tiers de l'équipement à bord
des sous-marins français selon le
contrat qui avait été signé entre la
france et l'australie étaient confiées à
une société américaine lockheed martin
puisque tous les systèmes d'armes de
combat de navigation déjà dans le
contrat était français seule la coque et
bus devait être française et c'est
justement il y avait un transfert de
technologie qui devait être donné par la
france à savoir faire à l'australie et
c'est ça qui rend si vous voulez le
point de vue français encore plus
nerveux parce que on avait quand même
consenti à beaucoup de concessions pour
faire plaisir aux australiens si je
termine merci ce sera le mot la
conclusion merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat s'il matelly votre
livre géopolitique de l'économie et
publié aux éditions eyrolles merci
également à nicole bacharan et je
rappelle le titre du livre que vous
publiez avec dominique simonet les
grands jours qui ont changé l'amérique
c'est chez perrin